[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum thanks for tuning in
if you're here for Marina background
hopefully you'll like the interview and
you'll subscribe and listen it's free
it's everywhere you can watch on YouTube
listen whatever uh we'd appreciate it so
always looking for listeners there's a
lot of podcasts out there as you know
and uh hopefully
you'll stick around
um follow us on our handles at inside of
you podcast on Instagram and Facebook
and at inside you pod on the Twitter uh
we're also on patreon uh if you want to
be a patron support the podcast and give
back the pot the patron save the podcast
don't they Ryan they do they really
without them I couldn't do it go to
patreon.com inside of you I will try to
message you back and uh join the patron
family a lot of perks and boxes from me
and science stuff yeah whatever you know
it's all there and the inside of you
online stores I got these cool art this
cool artist
and all the information is on the inside
of you online store they made these
statues they're like um of me from
Smallville these Bronze Statues like
they're expensive stuff like and so we
just made nine
and so you know I was like hey let's see
it's something different let's see if
people want them they're unique they're
signed by me so I don't check that [__]
out if you want anyway Marina background
is awesome she's a friend she did a
movie with me called back in the day
which not a lot of people saw but people
saw it mostly like it except critics
um and uh she's done so much I mean
Homeland and
um
Greenland a lot of lands
um Serenity and V and I could go on and
on Deadpool one Deadpool 2 we talk about
uh her possible return for Deadpool
three we'll see what happens and uh
she's just always great we talk about
family and life and stress and how she
deals with it and uh we talked a lot
about a lot of good stuff it's just so
easy to talk to and uh I just love this
girl I do in a very friendly way because
she's got a heart of gold and I've known
her for God 10 years now and uh yeah
beautiful inside out and uh
let's just do it let's get inside of
Marina background it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience I got a joke for you what a guy
uh comes out of the bathroom and says to
his wife I looked in the mirror and I am
old I am wrinkly it's disturbing I look
disgusting please just tell me something
nice about myself and he she says well
you have perfect eyesight
come on good dad joke to start off the
day
how's it you're full of dad jokes I am
yeah I am that's what I love about you
how's that how's old Ben McKenzie doing
uh he's good he's got some good dad
jokes too um it's pretty bad he's really
into that kind of humor he's doing great
he's about to release his book a book
yes you gotta talk to him he um during
the pandemic he went down this whole
Rabbit Hole of like well first you know
oh my God I'm stuck in a house with my
entire family for how long then
he started to play the market and then I
don't know he can explain this better me
long story short he started to follow
crypto and realized like
this shit's [__] up and so then he
started betting against it and making
money
betting against crypto yeah and then he
realized that
he that it's a bubble that it's going to
burst and that it's all fraud and he
started writing a book about it and
literally everything started to fall
apart as his book is coming out are you
serious yes he should be in the stock
market he should be like on Wall Street
he should be he has actually has a
degree in economics but he decided to
become an actor
how am I how do I I'm just so bad with
numbers and money and understanding
things and I feel so like you know when
my business manager sits there and goes
all right well this is I go well what's
that it's one it's I'm not as bad so my
stepdad
love him nice guy and I'm not kidding he
talks like this Michael
your mother was
[__] up the television
can you can you come over and do
something
that's Gordon
but Gordon I don't know if I should tell
this story I mean it might so my friend
was selling their house
okay and we're just gonna make up
numbers it was in Indiana it's not a lot
of money for an Indiana house but let's
say he said look
we want to sell your house for a hundred
thousand
and Gordon said okay
and then my buddy came back and said
okay
we're gonna we're gonna sell it now for
90. we're gonna go for 90. he goes well
who gets the 10 000.
guess what are you talking about he goes
well you said a hundred
but now we're selling it for 90. it
sounds like you're a stepdad who get
that's what I'm talking about my stepdad
okay I thought you're talking about your
friends sorry I know who gets the ten
thousand it's like
Gordon let me explain something to you
if you sold a car for twenty thousand
dollars and the guy wanted just to pay
you 15 instead
you understand what I'm saying and you
said yes
oh
to this day
my friend Ken's like you cannot tell
Gordon about I said that he'll be pissed
I think it's hilarious though but I'm
not as bad as that I think numbers are
you have to have a certain kind of brain
to understand I'm terrible at numbers I
I'm doing this at dinner to calculate
tip you know what I mean did you do that
on purpose did you marry someone who is
just like you wanted no that was a bonus
that was not a part of the something I
knew about
so what was it I mean look obviously
he's a good looking guy he's smart but
was it because you just had a crush on
Jim Gordon detective Gordon or like his
giant penis I mean oh welcome to
welcome to the podcast inside of you
brought to you by Viagra
whoa he's got a big one okay I mean
whatever
everything's good there but if yeah what
it would I I I for me everything is
about emotional connection and we
connected in a way that I hadn't ever
with anybody and um that was it they got
you
we got each other
what kind of baggage does he get when he
marries someone like you a very fiery
Brazilian gorgeous talented I am perfect
I don't have any flaws being married to
me is a walk in the park what's the one
thing that he that you know that he
struggles with that just like he's like
oh my gosh we're talking about this
yesterday actually
I thrive in chaos
he wants to run and hide
I during the pandemic I was like oh my
God we get to be home all the time
together everybody he's like
you know
um when usually between like 4 P.M and
bedtime
my house is utter chaos the kids are
home from school everybody's got energy
we try to get them outside when we can't
you know my nine-year-old is hitting the
soccer ball against the TV the baby is
screaming about something and the
seven-year-old is just trying to figure
out how she can fit in one of the worlds
that you know she's like the typical
middle child like what do I do kind of
thing and it's utter chaos and dishes
are clanking and dinner's being made and
then clean up and all that and Ben is
not around during this time he's like on
a meeting out for a walk
he's like tell me when dinner is
did that bother you did that bother you
in the beginning were you like no you
have to kind of help me with this yeah I
mean because it bothers me still and we
talked about it last night
I need you around like I want you around
like I want to hang out with you like
it's not even like help me I want to
hang on there are children
oh my God I yeah I think I'd be that too
I think I'd be overwhelmed and you're
not overwhelmed you're sort of you
thrive in chaos like you said driving
chaos I when things are hard when I have
a job and I'm worried about the kids and
there's something going on at the school
and whatever like I'm like okay I'm
gonna get all the stuff done however I
do like lose it I mean I I obviously
have a threshold for me it's the whining
it's like certain things like really
trigger me big time yeah are you a
screamer are you a yeller I can yell are
you is it a powerful yellow or more like
Arthur do not do that no it's not that
controlled it's like oh my God
shut up you know when I finally lose it
and what happens do they pay attention
yes everybody goes oh
you know and Ben does not do that Ben's
more like okay let's just calm down here
it can get snippy you know he can get
like
just stop doing that yeah
oh my gosh I just what I don't
understand is how people have you know
couples have like three kids
and they have careers how does Ben have
time to write a book during all this how
do you have time to prepare for movies
learn your lines do end game which
obviously got canceled thanks for
bringing that up and um all these things
that you do but how do you honestly I
mean it's it's a
like I I couldn't do that if I don't
have mine you could Your Capacity grows
for like for chaos for getting [__] done
like you suddenly find hours in time
where you didn't before it's not easy
I'm in a Perpetual state of
forgetting something or dropping the
ball somewhere or not being there for
someone all the time there is no you
just become more accustomed
to like disappointing everybody all the
time you know like friends and work and
sometimes I show up to work and I'm like
oh [__] that's the scene we're doing
today [__] I forgot to look at it you
know
it's like it's chaos but
if you're present with it like it's it
is it's fine like
I don't know I think you know I sort of
I'm okay with that
um he
he needs more Ben needs more structure
he got an office out of the house in
order to write this book and he gave
himself like x amount of hours a day
like I'm at this office no matter what
happens or what's going on at home and
for the most part
he stuck to it is there a rule like you
can't call me unless no there's no rule
he's very responsive if I need something
and I've learned that he goes like
in and out like he's really focused hard
in and then he's like [__] around for
10-15 minutes and then he's like back in
you know like we all have our ways that
we work but I know that he works you
know he leaves sometimes at six or six
thirty before anybody's even off and
then comes home
but that's when I'm like okay then
you're home for the evening I want to
see your [__] face
so you I I'm sensing that you miss him
you miss each other of course I do I
well that's and that's what's great too
is having the space
yeah and and there's plenty of time for
passion there is because we're doing
different things and we have things to
talk about and we have passions outside
of each other
I mean you know whenever he's like he
just shot a pilot I it was in Vancouver
I had shot a movie
he came and he dumped the kids off with
me in Atlanta when I was finishing he
went off to do a pilot I brought the
kids home we sort of like tag team
parented we hadn't seen each other
in like two months other than like one
or two nights and then you have
something to talk about you want to hear
about each other's jobs works or
whatever and check in with each other
again it's it's kind of great
um all right enough about Ben and his
huge penis
um
you know uh what's up with Deadpool
three
you know fans want to know anything uh
any scoop yeah what is Apple Deadpool
three that's a really good question
I have to be very diplomatic about what
I say here
um
I'd like to be in it they have called me
about being in it
um right now we have not agreed
on terms
um and everybody's trying their best and
doing their best
they may not it may or may not work out
I don't
know all right
um but you're an integral part of that
you know serious would you call it a um
I'd like to think so I do think that
this movie
um since the acquirement of you know
Deadpool Universe by Marvel Disney all
that thing all that that merger that
happened I do feel like
they're trying to reinvent it a little
bit I think this movie is going to be
much more about
um Wolverine and Deadpool
um and that's known right that's not a
secret
yeah yeah that's known yeah he's I mean
who he was going to be a huge part of it
and I'm sure he'll be great
now do you and Ryan ever just text each
other like hey congratulations on that
or hey what's up how are you yeah I do
all the time whenever he has children
which now is a lot of them I'm just
congratulating him on that
I also do get called a lot too he's he
has a lot of honors he's a lot of
like he's being honored by I think
lately it was uh the cinematech
organization whatever the [__] they're
they're called and then there was like
some Canadian award and they wanted
they've been wanting me to like do
videos non-stop for that stuff and I'm
like Ryan one more and I'm done that's
it
but I love him I really do he's a great
guy he's a really um
straight shooter hard worker
[__] funny as [__] and he's there for
you when you're doing your lines when
you're he's he's right there
because some actors yeah yeah he's very
um he's present and he's uh a team
player he's always trying to improve you
know like I don't I'm not a
a sensitive actor in that sense of like
if you have an idea for me I'd love to
hear it I you know I'll try anything
um if you're gonna make me better
fantastic
um so he's we work well together in that
way he uh you know he's very Hands-On
and he's like try this so what about
that or does this make sense and you
know changing lines all the time or
whatever it's fun really so you're all
it keeps you on your toes
definitely keeps you on your toes it's a
lot of improv that happens a lot of
improv do you like that or do you like
I'm more of a scripted person I want to
know my stuff and but I don't like
people throwing [__] at me I think
depending on what you're doing
um if you're doing Shakespeare I
certainly don't want to improv that [__]
um but yeah we're doing it something
like Deadpool
it's fun you know
um
especially if you know a character
really well you can have a good time but
it can also be really scary
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look if you're
thinking of giving you therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside this podcast is
brought to you by Dove men plus care
guys do you get distracted during the
day thinking about your underarm
sweating or itching or emitting an odor
oh do those thoughts keep you from
showing care when it counts new and
improved Dove men plus care
antiperspirant with 72 hours sweat and
odor protection and one quarter
moisturizing cream helps you forget
about your underarms so you can be
present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improve Dove men plus
care antiperspirant or ever personal
care products are sold
yeah you know that that I I saw some
interview and you were talking about and
maybe this is old but I you didn't get
really deep into it but like the stunt
that got cut where you're underwater and
a chair tied to a chair
like that gave me anxiety just hearing
that because I don't like being
underwater in fact I'd rather be in
space alone than underwater alone
I totally hear that that was one of them
like the most difficult thing I've ever
had to do at work was it traumatic was
it dramatic it was I I think about that
and I go like I can't breathe and it
wasn't even in the film made me so mad
what exactly happened so they put you
under there you didn't have any kind of
well it was just
a tank and it was used for the second
film because my character is
spoiler alert dead and
um
she's in this ethereal universe and so
they were gonna try to take our
movements underwater and make it look
like we're weren't we weren't underwater
I think there's a Green Day music video
like this where like you know like the
hair starts to float and my boobs were
like up to here which is one of the
reasons why it really didn't work
because I'm in a tank top and like my
foods are here you know everything
floats
um
so we trained to be underwater doing
dialogue and they sunk the entire
apartment in a tank underwater
uh and we had to be restrained not
restrained but weighed down
so that I could sit in a chair because
as you float
um and it had to be deep enough where
you could get lights and cameras and
things in there
and the director spoke to us through
like a speaker underwater and I had a
diver at my feet who was ready to give
me oxygen when I needed it but it wasn't
an you know it had a roof like I was in
an apartment
so it had like a an escape
room to find but it was also really dark
you know and it was Panic inducing and I
really was just the whole time working
on like I can do this like I'm just
taking deep breaths I'm only 10 feet
under water like it's not a big deal or
you know it was awful and every time I
needed you go like this and they come
and they give you and I would Panic that
like if I don't blow I don't have enough
air left to blow out the bubbles and
then be able to take a deep breath if I
choke on this thing on 10 15 feet under
water that's a long way up to like be
joking you know yeah I I had the same
thing on the pilot of Smallville I
thought they'd fire me I was in a
12-foot tank and listen to this they put
me in a port like the Porsche that Clark
rescues me from there and they put
weights on me and I could hear the
director and it's this murky water it's
supposed to be a lake and
and I freak out and go up to the top and
like the third time I go to Tom I go
They're Gonna fire me I can't do this
I can't do this I can't this is
I I I'm I'm having flashbacks it was
just yeah it's awful I finally got it
and it and it worked but it was
absolutely
terrifying it's horrible yeah and I
didn't have to really have my eyes open
your eyes had to be open that was yeah
so that was the other thing I think that
made it worse was we were talking to
each other we couldn't have bubbles
coming out because it was supposed to
not look like we were underwater so we
had to like
you have to release a little air clear
all the bubbles from your face make sure
you can open your mouth on top without a
bubble coming out do the dialogue scene
and hang out there and wait take a
breath and do it all over again and keep
and have your eyes open as I could
barely see him well they didn't
anticipate was that there's particles
and things in
the pillows that were attached to the
couch the wood
credenza whatever the [__] like things
had it started to float into the water
and both Ryan and I got really severe
eye infections are you serious we
couldn't open our eyes for like two days
did they have to like cancel production
for two days yes
so it's pretty much like pink eye it
kind of but worse like it felt like I
had razors in my eyeballs like I
couldn't open my eyes
were you miserable honestly like were
you like miserable to be around you were
so miserable no I was like a good sport
about it and then I like cried when I
got home
did why did you cry because of the fear
my baby was with me I had like a four or
five months Frankie was five months old
at the time or something and our nanny
who had been on the clock for like 12
hours and then I get home and I can't
even open my [__] like on the car
ride home I was like this
and I was just like please just let it
get easier you know and then I would try
to open my eyes and it felt like razor
blades and I'm like at home with a baby
and I can't even open my eyes I'm like
how am I gonna put her to bed
um it's really traumatic that that just
sounds cool terrible I mean they sent
baskets and baskets of things and like
doctors and they're like we're so sorry
and everything was fine I recovered
totally fine there weren't any lasting
damages but it was like it was harrowing
how many takes
it was I think like a 14-hour day like
underwater
so I don't know how many takes a million
takes like God
did you ever panic and go I gotta go up
I gotta go up yes how many time many
times and towards the end I was looking
at the director of David Legion I was
like I'm done I was like I can't I just
I I can't do this anymore
like just one more time just one more
time we almost got it I'm like okay
and you said that for like two hours you
know and were you bum did you ever see
the footage
I never saw the footage
like a screenshot
would you love to see the footage or do
you just want to get that button you
would
well guys start tweeting the director
what's his name David Leech David Lynch
leech David Leech I know I know yeah
yeah
oh my God that's trauma have you ever
had any other traumatic experiences on
set I just did on what
I just shot a movie called elevation uh
who's in it
we were it's it it's it it's sounds
Preposterous but it's really actually
awesome it's set
uh above 8 000 feet it's at a time where
there are these bugs these things kind
of catch out of the earth and sort of
just annihilating people and if you live
above 8 000 feet they can't go above
that
and so there's this refuge and you know
we we've been living like this for years
and I'm a scientist and I'm trying to
and I'm trying to figure out
how we kill these things and we have to
go on this journey me and Anthony Mackey
to the hospital
um because he needs something for his
kid who's got an illness and I need to
go to my lab to get the thing that's
going to help us figure out how to kill
these things and
through this journey obviously we
encounter them we run we are you know
it's it's really cool and one of the
things that we have to do
um we're on a ski run and we're trying
to get out we're trying to get up above
8 000 feet as fast as possible we decide
to use this ski lift and but these
things start knocking down the lines and
the thing like drops like we're in a ski
lift that is in the film it's supposed
to be like I don't know 30 feet in the
air or something and then it just like
drops down obviously they weren't going
to put us on a ski lift and drop us 30
feet but on the Sound Stage they rigged
this whole thing and they
put us up there
20 feet I don't actually know how many
feet but then it drops and
I was not prepared like I don't do
roller coasters I don't do fast rides
like I have severe anxiety but I don't
Skydive I I'm fine
just going for a run
right
but I'm on the scale left and they're
like we're just gonna drop you
it'll be fine
you have to jump out but only when after
it stops swinging and I'm like so much
information the thing drops I felt my
stomach inside my mouth I was like oh my
God and Eva K was running
and I literally turned to attracted
were you serious
yes I was serious
so it's great I was like I'm not doing
that again that was shaking oh my God
but you did it again
one more time who was the director this
guy George nopi
wow you know I I I I'm sure this is
going to be great elevation when is it
out
um I don't know it's an indie so we are
they're still they're still
you know putting it together there's
still some special effects I need to go
in so probably a little while but it's
gonna be cool I saw Greenland would you
say Greenland or Greenland
Greenland's Greenland Ryan Greenland
Greenland
I don't know Greenland I say Greenland
Greenland like Newfoundland Greenland
Whitney Queensland
um I don't know it's what I think
um I saw Greenland
yeah no see I wasn't right Greenland
Greenland Greenland
um and I used to play hockey with the
director his name is Rick Wise you know
I love Rick yeah let me tell you he's a
good director yes his movies some of the
movies aren't you know as good as others
but like Greenland was really good and
Fallon was really good yeah um he and
and that was an action movie I really
enjoyed it and you see it you're like oh
I know what this is It's Gonna and I had
so much fun with it and Gerard Butler
was great your Chemistry was great your
emotional you're real you're playing
such a a crazy situation but I think
that's the key as an actor to really
commit really be as grounded as you can
be and that's the only way for a movie
like that to work
agreed and I think that's what attracted
me to that part so much was that there
was an emotional
uh anchor
you know it was a little we of course we
were shooting green screen and watching
comets flying from the sky sorry there's
yeah it's New York it's Brooklyn
whatever wherever you live Queens New
York yeah whatever
do you know one time I was in and I
wanted you to finish that thought but I
was I was in New York City and I was
walking down the street and these uh
ambulances drove by loud sirens blaring
and this woman goes shut up and I go
they're saving people
I don't
get annoyed numbers are just so annoyed
at everything stop
it you don't have to be that way like
it's a petulant child yeah yeah but yeah
Greenland
um anyway yeah I just you know I had a
very strong emotional anchor I have kids
I love I lose my kid in that movie I
can't imagine anything horrible more
horrible for a parent and so it was
really easy to tap into not easy but um
how
and then same with this movie I just did
the character has a lot of baggage and
there's a lot of like emotional strong
stuff that anchors
the story and I can't do a movie where
I'm just like
I don't know I can't imagine being on a
set and having an act and have no
emotional connection to my character or
something that I'm playing that I give a
[__] about yeah I feel I feel that way I
mean I understand like you're I think
now in your career it's like if there's
not substance if there's not something
that I can remember it's not worth it
unless it's a lot of money
or a lot of fun a lot of fun a lot so
three variables a lot of money a lot of
fun or
really good yeah
one of those or a combo of those I mean
you get all three you hit the jackpot
would you do something that is just not
going to be any fun it's not going to be
much money but it's good
really it's good absolutely
I have this like I this like
desire to like make art which we don't
get to do really that's so Juilliard I
know I can't believe it plays anymore
forget that you want two plays
nonetheless it's phenomenal but I can't
I am exhausted at the idea
getting paid 800 a week if you're lucky
to get up there for three hours a night
and like
exercise your soul you know like I just
can't do it and it's stress you're
stressed all day you're thinking about
the show it's anxious day it's just it's
not even about not being paid that much
it's also just like
the emotional roller coaster ride I I
love filming I love movies TV shows you
get to like
tone the performance and like think
about it and like fine tune it like
there's something really satisfying
about that I finally watched Black Swan
I had never seen it
and that was freaking amazing yeah that
was intense as [__] and Natalie Portman
almost I was just like I was surprised
because I've never seen her like that I
was like yeah yeah she's in Star Wars
she's fine she's good yeah now I'm like
whoa no wonder she won best actor I mean
she was on another level and the work
she put into it but then I I read that
you were her understudy in the seagull
checkoffs the seagull
how close were you with her not that
close I mean she's she was a big star at
that point already and I was just
graduating school and
I was an understudy which you know
there's a definitely hierarchy in
theater
um
I was jealous I was pissed I was very
nice of course I was done I want to play
this part so yeah right and I got to do
it once I got to do it for a dress
rehearsal
and it was awesome I learned so much
but I I think also being young and
having just graduated Juilliard and
having a chip on my shoulder like I
should be doing this part
but I think you know the me of today we
very much appreciated that she was she
was really like working hard and putting
herself out there that is that is not an
easy role was she nice though she was
super nice
just we didn't work better that well she
was super nice I mean that had to be
nervous for an understudy to I mean do
you have to watch every show yeah you
have to be there every night you have to
watch every show I mean you listen
backstage you know when when you're in
the performances like you're not in the
audience but you're there just in case
how many performances they do of that
trail that was not that much because of
Shakespeare in the park so I think it's
a limited run it's like four weeks or
something right all right so that's not
bad because I was thinking you were on
there for three six eight months doing
this no way no way could I do that no
way
no way wow though I mean that's I mean
really they say you know people will
come up to me or they'll come up to
other actors and they'll say how should
I get started I'm like do theater take
class you have to it's all about
experience it's all about
learning the crap people think they
could jump in and a lot of people do
especially nowadays with the you know
YouTubers and all the
they become
how do you feel about all this it's a
very sad day when my my nine-year-old
was like I'm gonna be a YouTuber I was
like okay no but that's what they all
say now you know yeah I guess um
I mean I don't know it's all I think
it's an oversaturation of
life like if some things aren't
left to the imagination or a mystery
what's the point you know yeah yeah no I
I agree I agree what um do you still get
I know you have kids I know you have
chaos you thrive in chaos we've talked
about that but do you still get like
real anxiety or deal with any kind of
like depression or things and how do you
work around that oh my God for sure I do
two things I deal with I struggle with
quite a bit one is
um PMS like legit depression from PMS
um debilitatingly so I take a very low
dose Prozac when I'm PMSing and then I
stop I just need to take it for like
a short period of time and then the rest
of the month I don't need to be on it
but I've noticed that is a game changer
for me and I had a stigma around that
for the longest time my doctor had
suggested it forever ago and I was like
I need antidepressants I'm not depressed
like uh but I was like why am I not
trying something that my doctor is gonna
is telling me it might work
um
I stopped snapping at my kids my husband
my you know like the the part that made
me
um
like just have like a low threshold for
emotional stuff like kind of went away
it's crazy and awesome it's really a
game changer and I highly recommend that
women take it seriously PMS is something
that is seen as like optional or like
you're making a big deal out of it it's
legit and as you get older and you have
kids I mean all that stuff changes
constantly
that and then anxiety at work like I
still when I get a script or it's my
first day on the job like I don't sleep
the night before I'm always terrified I
don't want to [__] up I'm terrified I'm
not gonna I'm gonna disappoint everybody
they're gonna be like oh I can't believe
what hurt her you know
every time still get that
every time and then once you're complete
a scene or find it and you're like okay
then you're good
yeah I have this thing where I feel like
I'm gonna be found out like
yeah this is the job where they're like
oh she's not that talented she's just
pretty it's fine
you know and every time I am genuinely
shocked surprised happy that somebody
takes me seriously and that somebody
goes
you have something to offer of course I
do and I should earn that and believe
that and like come in with that right
this is why I think men are a lot more
successful at times than women
like I get
like I feel like I don't deserve it or
something it's
yeah that's silly to think that you
don't deserve it and you know what's
funny is I'm saying that because I I do
the same thing
why are you nervous why are you not
trusting yourself and sometimes you
could be so great in a scene so
committed so intense so everything you
knew you could do deep down and it works
but then the next time you forget about
how good you were and you're back to
square one all insecure unsure of
yourself and I I'm like I have to be
insane yeah yeah you know it's crazy
it's crazy and it's crazy making because
I think and and this is where
I do think this like small amount of
Prozac has helped
um is that it shuts that down a little
bit for me
even though that's more associated with
anxiety or whatever but the self-doubt
part I think comes from like a
depression and or like a
value thing you know and and it shuts
that down a little and it makes me able
to be a little bit more daring a little
bit more
um
let me see what happens if I do this
thing that I want to do
yeah you know I I really appreciate you
talking about that because I never
I've never had any guests or anyone talk
about like PMs and depression with that
and taking Prozac and like the stigma
that's attached to all these
antidepressants or anti-anxiety but
people's brains are different the
genetics are different sometimes you're
inherently you have these things and
it's how you deal with them like I don't
need this I don't need that I'm it's all
natural I could beat this sometimes you
need a little help
therapy whatever it is this makes things
easier why not make things easier for
yourself so you can focus on the harder
stuff
yeah I agree I think that's awesome I
didn't know that I always thought you
know women had PMs and they're like oh
here we go this is this this time all
right this this is the week this is yeah
you know nice you're clear spear clear
and I'm like oh but I didn't realize how
severe it can be for a lot of women yeah
I have a friend who has also something
called pmdd which is something nobody
talks about which is Extreme PMS where
like you really like something women get
suicidal during that time that's intense
man to deal with that monthly
it's like postpartum yeah I mean that's
what it sounds like it's like you know
that stuff's real I remember I don't
talk about it much but my friend Nate
um he had he was married and um it's
this wonderful woman Amy and uh they
just had their newborn Alexa
and uh his mom called me one day
she goes hey Mike and I'm like hey Mama
Mama Shepherd what's up
Amy's gone and I go oh my God they broke
up no he goes no no we lost her
oh my God she yeah she um
she overdosed accidentally on sleeping
pills like took the whole bottle and
didn't wake up
and there were some signs but they just
didn't know so this [__] is real and
yeah and I had to fly back the neck I
flew to Indiana the next day and stayed
with him for two weeks and changed
diapers till two in the morning like
every morning with him and stayed up
with him and cried with him and yeah
it's real it's real that's really
um
it's real it's real
um would you ever do anything again with
the whole Firefly Serenity world yeah
I wasn't too confident
some things to rest I love those people
with all of my heart
I just kind of feel like it was what it
was and now we're like
20 years older and like yeah we should
do a reunion we should do like a
podcast or a talk or like a one-off like
friends did that would be fun right
I don't really need to resuscitate the
show for me I think you still look young
hey thanks yeah I do I think you still
look young
um you and you ever talked about it but
some actors have I had Nathan Fillion
and stuff maybe you don't want to talk
about it but what was your experience
with Joss Whedon
oh it was fine actually I I have no like
horrible stories or feelings towards him
he's
you know he could be a little like
egotistical and like but what showrunner
is I've not met a showrunner that is not
overly confident but you never saw what
the other people see you just weren't
privileged I didn't which does not let
me just be very clear invalidate
anything or or I'm not saying anybody's
making anything up like I I that was not
my experience
um we got along well I also think I
I don't I mean I've certainly
experienced
um sexism and weird situations at work
like most women have but I I don't it's
I don't
um
leave a lot of room for that if that
makes sense like I don't
I'm kind of a straight shooter you know
this about me so if somebody
is going to say something or do
something I think I would deal with it
immediately yeah oh yeah you would
immediately if you don't like something
you let everybody know yeah you have
that Mirena look I know that look that
you're in your lip you know you're kind
of like I just I I remember that look I
remember being set with you and it was
just it didn't happen often but if you
were like a little bit like uh okay what
are we what's going on what's going on
what are we doing like seriously and but
you were nice about it you were just
like everybody knew without you saying
anything you know what I mean I have a
feeling that Ben probably knows that
look I guess
yes but again Serenity and Firefly I
understand it's like put it to rest it's
like unless they came up with some great
idea and they said this is going to be a
one out movie
um we're gonna do for TV and it made
sense it was a great script you'd
consider it maybe yeah for sure I mean I
I love the group everybody has a very
like
like special place in my heart it was
like my like my first TV job I was so
excited and Nathan was awesome like
everybody was great I had like nothing
but good feelings about that but I'm
also like I've moved on and I wouldn't
even know what it would feel like to
like go back and play that part again
you know
do you ever look back and all the people
you've worked with and go man I can't
believe that guy or that woman didn't
become a star like I really thought that
person was going to Skyrocket
you know working with someone and going
this person this person's got it and
then you're like huh whatever happened
with them I mean they work and stuff but
I always thought they'd be way bigger
right right
interesting right it is interesting to
think about
I wonder if people say that about me
okay no I think everybody thought oh
she's she's a star I think when you have
talent and looks
both you you you're it's a slam dunk
with me it was like I had a little
talent I was okay looking
so it was like I had to really push the
talent part I had to really show people
no no
no I swear to God because listen I
always say this but like look when I
when I was on Smallville I mean look
around me everybody was way better
looking than me would you attest to that
Ryan admit it
are you fishing still I'm not fishing
Tom Kristen uh Whitney uh everyone was
good looking because it was a WB show CW
Show and that includes you oh yeah right
anyway it's not about me but
um yeah but can you think of anybody or
someone who you were like no this
person's not gonna be I or I I don't I
didn't expect this person to be such the
star they are how about that I I
honestly can't think of a person but I'm
also somebody who like
in my younger days when I was working I
underestimated everybody and now I'm
like the opposite where I'm like oh my
God everybody's so amazing do you know
what I mean because I also have perspect
I think it comes with perspective of
career of how hard this is of like the
miracle of like what is it five percent
of members of sag are working like it's
hard to do what we do and to
consistently get jobs
but I don't know I've never worked with
anybody where I was like oh that
person's gonna be ginormous
um
yeah yeah all right
um Always Sunny in Philadelphia we both
did the first season you did the pilot I
love those guys I love that wrexham show
about the soccer team it's brilliant
mcelhaney's awesome he used to sleep on
my couch I don't know why he only gave
me one episode of sunny but he did thank
you Rob I love you um he's not listening
and um
but that's a show which I told him on
the podcast which I don't know if he
appreciated but I'm very you know candid
and open I said
I did that I go yeah of course I'll do
that
this this will never do anything
what's a what I just didn't I I never
thought that that show would even how I
mean it became huge right right because
it wasn't because of the the the quality
in terms of the writing and the fun it's
a very specific kind of humor it is and
it wasn't even that it was just like I
got there and there was I was sitting in
a chair as my trailer outside and uh you
know they had no money and uh you know
we were just like going speed of light
and it was like one take moving on and
like it was it just felt like we're
doing a student film and I was like
huh I don't I don't know what's going on
did you feel that doing the pilot I
dated Glenn in college we were what did
I know this I don't know I feel like
maybe you did Glenn fidditch
uh we know I don't think we talked about
it I don't know we were boyfriend
girlfriend most of college actually you
want the Juilliard
yeah
and then I met and then we moved out
here and he always he was he's also
another one that was like he's a really
healthy ego
um and I love it
love the guy we are friends still
um
he told me about the show when him and
Rob were and Charlie were like creating
this and this is what I mean about guys
and girls
I wouldn't think to do that I was 22 and
I was like I what am I gonna do between
auditions like I have to wait for
somebody to call me and send me another
Edition these guys were out there making
[__] they were like they borrowed a
camera they would film things they lived
on like Crescent Heights or Blended and
they would like film things up and down
and I was like what a bunch of losers
you know like
but they're being creative they're using
their smarts they're I mean why why not
why can't they do that right like I just
did not give myself the permission and
they did and they did it and I'm like I
think that's awesome it was such a that
was such a huge lesson to me watching
them go through that process so I was
not even in the pilot I was in the
whatever they shot a pilot themselves to
show it to three yards to go hey will
you help us produce this thing and then
they remade the pilot and I couldn't do
it
um but
when we were doing that I was like this
is so stupid
but I had a great time and then seeing
it later I was like yeah of course it's
their humor it's hilarious like it is
who they are and they did it like they
did it all by themselves it comes to
show you folks that
you can do it yourself especially
nowadays with the iPhone oh my God and
we talk about it all the time it should
more important you should just go shoot
everything I should be going to do that
this stuff and it's just like I have you
know just go do it you have an idea
shoot it if it sucks par for the course
but if you learned something and it but
you might just hit that lightning in a
bottle
yeah but I remember they took that they
showed me the pilot at my house I had a
little uh house that I rented had rats
in the ceiling
um
and I remember watching and I remember
going
yeah all right man good job guys awesome
and they left and I go good for them but
I I just how is that gonna get be on TV
I don't I don't get it I mean he said
that I didn't get it I just was like it
just doesn't look great
dude it's one of the most successful
shows ever and it's a great show but
like I would somebody saw if I was an
executive
I I would have been like oh I don't know
I don't think so
and some smart Nick grad over there at
FX saw what it could be that's why that
sometimes there's guys or girls or
whatever they that can really make see
something that we don't see yeah that's
a gift man absolutely
would you do that again if someone goes
hey we're gonna do this like Sizzle
thing when you want to keep yeah and I
have like I you know
it's super fun Ben and I do stuff like
that all the time actually we're
trying to do a seller uh
eating show I guess cooking it's not
cooking it's like
it's about travel and immigration and
culture and eating all right this is
called [__] talking with Marina
background these are yeah yeah these are
my patrons they make the show happen I
love you guys patreon.com inside of you
to become a patron and uh we're here
with my dear dear friend Marina I hope
we're friends forever
no matter how famous you get you're
already really famous
I'm not that famous but if I get more
famous I'll always be your friend you'll
even do the podcast if you like get
nominated for if you get nominated for
an Oscar or a Golden Globe you already
got nominated for an Emmy you want no
you got nominated yeah I didn't win
that's all right sorry to bring that up
um but if you ever get nominated for an
Oscar
you can't say oh I'm just doing
suppressed I don't have time for your
little podcast you have to do it we'll
never say that Michael you heard it here
because that happens sometimes there's a
couple people that I'm like uh
oh yeah he's just busy on a press tour
again [__] you
this is rapid fire tell me how your
parents decided on naming you Morena I
think you said this before but go ahead
yeah so my mom it you know this was the
70s in Brazil
um there's two stories I think she's
lying about both but she had a makeup
artist who was named Marina I think and
and that inspired her and then uh she
played a character
that was a vampire whose name was Morena
maybe your mom did
your mom played a vampire yeah she was
an actor yeah yeah Brazil yeah she
played a vampire yeah but but with a
Portuguese accent what's this book
before she is in it yeah that's she's in
Brazil that's what I meant I I didn't
say it right at all you don't do an
accent when you speak the language but I
know what you mean how would you play a
vampire say it in Portuguese say I'd
like to suck your blood in Portuguese
come on do it
say it without a smile now
okay say
um I will kill you if you don't obey me
yeah
okay hold on but say it and don't blink
sounds looks powerful
do it please do it okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
if anybody's casting a Portuguese or a
Brazilian uh vampirus
that's pretty ridiculous uh Dana asks
what is your playlist of music top three
that you can't get enough of oh my God
it's all over the place
um Billy eilish any Billy eilish like
bad guy or
um
addiction
um flowers I'm obsessed I'm sorry can't
stop
and uh calm down it says Selena Gomez
participation
I'm not
I'm being serious here uh as you know
I'm stuck in the 70s 80s 90s I know I
could not name one Billy eilish song If
it was a gun to my head with a hundred
or a hundred million dollars in front of
me I couldn't name nothing I could not
name one song Selena Gomez I couldn't
name one song
I couldn't I could name um one Adele
song Rolling in the Deep because I would
really like that song you need to get
with the times there's some good music
up there there is some good music
there's this guy Gerardo Dorado
um Neil draw not Neil Gerardo I forgot
he's amazing my friend Kristen Ritter
took me to see him last week and and
that name drop and and he was really
good
um my opinion what is something you
haven't done professionally that you
want to a lot of things I haven't done a
period piece like a legit period piece
um can you do an English accent
eventually I'm not even gonna pull one
out right now no I didn't ask you how
about an Irish one
no way
you're a sheep stealing hood and bastard
yeah
Scott is that Scottish school is just
four from the back of your throat in
Irish you throw it Forward I believe
Richard Gerard Butler she could figure
it out
that's pretty good all right thanks Ray
h
say uh congratulations on the baby
congratulations on the baby all right uh
do you have any fun behind the scenes
stories from the Deadpool we just talked
about that sorry Ray Jessica B have you
ever found yourself in an embarrassing
situation where you just wished to
disappear I I every day probably
um probably walking into a glass door
at a birthday party that's probably the
worst one did I break
no
thank God Michelle K what's the one
character that stuck with you after you
wrapped
out of my characters stick with me I
have a real hard time being finished
with a job I get really like bummed and
depressed and
kind of like have this like weird
transition back to life and especially
if I've been away from home
coming back
I call it the re-entry is really rough
yeah because you give so much yourself
yeah and you're used to like
thinking about that character and like
having the time the luxury to like
obsess about it and
how do they think and do things and how
am I gonna play the scene or whatever
and then that person's just gone and
you're like left with this void
yeah complete what about like you know
uh it was called end game it was a
series that got canceled right how do
you deal at this stage in your career
because I'm sure like me in the
beginning if something gets canceled or
something doesn't happen you don't get
the part it weighs on you more do you
feel like you've uh matured or
emotionally matured in your response
physically and mentally to uh rejection
or cancellation
yeah I think
and this came with like having a family
and you know focusing on really what's
important I it doesn't I get bummed you
know and especially if it's something I
really love doing
it sucks but you're like okay well
something else is coming up I'm sure let
me enjoy this time with my family and
then sometimes when you're doing
something you're like this isn't as
great as I thought it would be I'd
rather be home with my kids and you're
like kind of glad that something doesn't
work out you know
um if Deadpool 3 doesn't work out for me
I'm gonna be really bummed it's
something that I
have a very deep emotional connection to
and have been around since the beginning
of it you know
um
but like what can you do like what's
important is my life in front of me yeah
that was well
said let me ask you this is there such
thing as love at first sight is there
such thing with Ben obviously discard
the OC days
but Gotham Knights
I mean
is there such thing as when you know you
know yeah
no hesitation there
did you have honestly and don't don't
milk it
I need an honest answer from you here
did you get like those butterflies those
endorphins for weeks
when things started happening
yeah and I I still do like it sounds so
cheesy we don't see each other for three
weeks
like I went to Vancouver to visit him
when he was shooting his Pilot we had
two nights together and I saw him again
I was like excited like my heart started
beating faster you know I
genuinely believe that is a real thing
and it comes from a deep emotional
connection it comes from getting someone
in a way you know it's not just about
looks or it's a chemical reaction to a
person
that
Deadpool said you know the puzzle pieces
fit together
it's like that and I didn't believe in
it before I met them
uh this is uh I I knew it'd be easy
I always go what are we going to talk
about and then we just kind of talk
yeah
it's great it's so much Insight like I
really love the stuff that you were
personal about and that
and just life in general and I I just
and any new Pro you have elevation
that's first of all I don't know how to
be any other way I think it's part of I
know that's why I love you you know you
know me I'm
open um
Edition is a new new movie
um I did this amazing movie also with
Pierce Brosnan that Philip Noyes
directed do you know Philip Noyes he did
rabbit proof fence and salt and Patriot
Games I mean phenomenal director
um we did this small indie
it was actually James Khan's last film
um I'm interviewing Scott next week his
son oh wow yeah it lives up the street
from me yeah he was a very sweet man
um anyway I love this movie it's um it's
sort of like about a hitman's last job
you know and you know how that goes
what's it called
it's called Fast Charlie
um I don't know when or if it'll ever
come out the producers are
being difficult complicated about
finishing the film but
I'm very proud of that I think elevation
will be good
[Music]
um
and yeah that's a lot that's a lot and
you have a family and and what's uh
Ben's book called It's called Easy Money
easy money
by Ben McKenzie no in July in July I
cannot wait to read that it's really
cool I've read it he got an interview
with Sam bankman freed
before
the collapse
fftx wow
it's really cool I wouldn't even know
what to say so the crypto how'd you get
the name for that
what are the ad Wizards who came up with
this one
I love you I do I adore you I I think
you're an amazing human being and I'm so
happy that we got art you got Francis
you got Julius you got you know and you
got me you're fourth your fourth kid
congratulations
can I go play now Mom that is literally
the constant conversation in her house
it's like do we have another one what
you're thinking of having another one
not really not in any serious way
I was gonna have something it's
addictive to make people
I guess so but like do you use
protection you should
I'm not gonna get any deeper with that
because I was going to say something
but like
it's possible
that doing that as We Know
Planned Parenthood stuff here Marina you
can have a fourth
I know what would the name be by the way
if you had another one it's gonna be a
girl by the way it would be a girl the
girl yeah
maybe after my grandmother
what's your name
lies lies
do you go by Marina background McKenzie
or just yeah Marina background well
actually Ben's last name is shanken
um
sounds like so I changed my name to
Marina instead of shankin
but I never use it because that's a
tough one oh you could use it you just
say maybe you and Ben should stop
shanking without protection
there you go all right I love you love
you bye
thank you Morena thank you hey Morena
what was that other song I think when I
interviewed her first I was like Morena
Monica
Monique there's some song from like
early 2000s not a great song
but I'm surprised at the song from the
early 2000s that I know it yeah yeah I
know it's kind of miraculous because I
don't listen to much of anything
um
but yeah I really love that interview
that's all I could say if you like the
interview too please subscribe give this
podcast a chance we need you listen
subscribe
um
follow us on our handles write a review
Boyd is that uh help and yeah inside of
your online store get some stuff and
last we're gonna say no no that was the
reviews help with the algorithm they do
they do if everyone out there would
write an engagement yeah it sure would
help so if you have the time write a
review and say hey we love the inside of
you podcast and it was fun and he asked
questions I would ask and I wanted it to
know or even just say this is great
listen to it or yay send uh
and thanks my patrons for making the
show possible and giving back to the
podcast patreon patreon.com inside of
you and become a patron today and I love
all my patrons and I'm gonna read all
the top tier patrons out right now all
their names they give back
thanks for listening you don't have to
listen to this if you don't want to but
these are the top tiers these I'm
listening to this
Ryan's listening I'm listening I'm here
Nancy D Leah s little Lisa Yukiko Jill e
Brian H still with me all these guys
Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C
Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy El Jamal F
Janelle B Mike e l Don Supremo 99 more
San Diego M Chad W Leanne P Janine r
Maya Pete one time somebody goes yeah
when you started reading all the names
and uh by the end I was just like man I
was like well you know you don't have to
listen if you don't want
yeah no the bird we're done you can
leave don't but don't leave but you can
but I might say something really
important at the end
like right there there's something that
happened Maya P Maddie asked Belinda and
Dave H hi Dave Sheila G Brad d Ray
tablet T Tom and Liliana a Talia M Betsy
D I haven't heard from her in a while
Chad L Dan and Angel M Rhiannon c chord
k-dip next in Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy
D Camille s Joey M Eugene and Sweet Leah
Corey Heather Locklear Heather L Jake B
Megan T Angela f m l s Orlando C
Caroline R Christine s Eric H Shane R
Emma R Andrew M zaroichi
77 that's correct well Andreas and
Oracle Karina and Amanda are Jen B Kevin
e Stephanie K jorel jam and Jay Leanne J
Luna R Cindy e Mike F Stone Edge Stone H
Stonehenge Miss s
Brian L Katie B and don't forget Aaron R
Kendall L House of Joelle Meredith I
Prof Dr scoots
Charlene C Cara C my Mary R Kyle f and
marisolfi Marisol P last but not least
thanks for listening thanks for loving
uh thanks for staying with us
Ryan yeah
tired today you yawned quite a few times
during the interview were you born with
the interview it was just long it was
longer it was a longer interview you
know some of these interviews are like
three hours like Rogan
the interview people three out can you
imagine that how lucky am I to be here
were you to stick to an hour oh yeah how
lucky am I I don't want to talk more
than an hour I want people to listen on
their way to work and if they don't wrap
it up they could certainly finish it up
in the first few minutes on the way home
I don't want people like going oh my God
I have to listen to this all week to be
clear it was a good interview but I
could but you can feel when it's
starting to get like the hour 15 like
okay it's we're over we're for sure over
an hour right now and I can feel it in
my legs I can feel it coming in the air
tonight
uh all right thanks for listening uh
Michael from Mike from the Hollywood
Hills in Hollywood California I'm
Michael Rosenbaum I'm right here on
Hollywood Hills a little way to the
camera we love you guys be good to
yourself and thanks for thanks for
listening or watching and uh thanks for
supporting the podcast we'll see
[Music]